bitcoin's price has been crashing but as
many of you probably already noticed my
conviction hasn't changed yesterday
aalir the ceo of slice he said exactly
that he specifically stated that my
conviction around bitcoin is on full
display even in the most uncertain times
and i couldn't stop but chime in and
explain that there is no price that will
shake my conviction bitcoin's price is
completely detached from the underlying
value and adoption of the network
long-term investors don't worry about
price they obsess over value and
durability i then went on an entire
little tweet threat i said that the hash
rate's at an all-time high lightning
network capacity all-time high bitcoin
addresses with 0.01 0.1 and one bitcoin
all at all time highs sentiment is very
bad on twitter right now and that's
because price drives sentiment it's the
most measurable thing it's volatile it's
true of every single asset but
correlations are trending towards one
because we are in a drawn out liquidity
crisis over the last eight months
price and value are not the same thing
though the missing aspect of the global
financial conversation is that all
assets even all the legacy safe havens
they're suffering at the hands of the
fed the fed's in control it's all one
big trade you have to underwrite the
value of assets not price during a
liquidity crisis there's only one
monetary policy globally that has not
changed over the last two years there's
only one monetary policy that's actually
independent and predictable the
short-term speculators they focus on
price but the long-term capital worries
about durability you should do your own
work and form your own opinion no one
knows what's gonna happen in just a few
hours right before the fed press
conference and in that moment we were
hours away from the announcement and
people were betting trillions of dollars
on the outcome you can't plan a business
or an investment portfolio around an
uncertain ever-changing future i'm
incredibly risk-averse i want
predictability and reliability in my
monetary policy this is why i bitcoin
and now you gotta ask yourself is
bitcoin for you hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you're subscribed like the
video and see you next time